we're gonna begin with this 13
Philadelphia police officers are
expected to be fired for posting racist
homophobic and threatening comments
online the posts were published in a
study by an independent research group
it uncovered around 3,000 offensive or
potentially offensive Facebook entries
dating all the way back to 2010 Don
Dahler is outside police headquarters in
Philadelphia
Don how many officers were involved in
this good morning well the police
commissioner says that more than 300
officers made offensive or potentially
offensive Facebook posting some of which
called for violence against racial or
religious minorities and in addition to
the officers who were fired others face
long term suspensions I continue to be
very angry and disappointed by these
posts many of which in my view violate
the basic tenets of human decency the
public Facebook posts from active
Philadelphia police included messages
like death to Islam another called
African Americans thugs and one offered
a threatening and profane version of the
Miranda rights you have the right to s
the f up anything you say will cause me
to effing throat punch you it's 300 and
some officers 72 off the street a whole
slew of information had to be going
through it's at the beginning of a
longer process can any officer who holds
these kinds of views be an effective
officer know when you have to care about
the people that you are protected after
the post were published by the Plainview
Project last month
community leaders demanded action as did
rapper and activist Meek Mill when he
spoke with Gayle King the making racist
comments and their bold about it I mean
they come to Buda and then it was never
really too many repercussions to it
after reviewing about 3100 offensive or
potentially offensive posts 17 officers
were singled out for demonstrating they
had little or no regard for their
position as police officers 13 will be
suspended with intent to dismiss the
remaining four will face a 30-day
suspension others involved will receive
training on social media and
professionalism how does this reflect on
adelphia I think it reflects on the
country and we have to step up and face
the problems that we have and try to try
to correct
no more firings are expected the police
union says they condemn the racist and
hateful language but they said they were
disappointed that these officers did not
receive due process they said that
they're working to protect their members
rights and that the overwhelming
majority of officers work with integrity
anthony done thank you 72 officers off
the street Philadelphia Wow many cases
will be impacted by those police
officers who have been fired okay meek
Mill's case at a police officer away
problems too so